i never thought that our story would end
as suddenly as it has
but it's filled with pages upon pages of
memories
and kept alive within my heart kanye
west is showing his support for dmx's
family
following the late rapper being laid to
rest team yeezy is now presenting a
million dollar gift
to dmx's loved ones
on saturday dmx's friends and family
gathered for a celebration of life
memorial
at new york's barclays center the
private event was produced by kanye and
featured a medley of performances from
his sunday service choir
[Music]
kanye and his yeezy brand also teamed up
with fashion house balenciaga
producing a limited edition tribute
shirt with proceeds going to dmx's
family
now i'm really sad because
we have lost a icon
and the best father anybody can ask for
and et has learned that in less than 24
hours after its debut
sales from the shirt have raised one
million dollars for dmx's loved ones
and that shirt is now completely sold
out
thank you thank you thank you thank you
for the energy that everyone has brought
here today
the celebration of how great
we all know dmx was
a source tells e.t that kanye traveled
to nyc
to oversee the elaborate memorial where
he produced the entire service with his
yeezy creative force behind him
where he also shared footage of dmx
leading his sunday service choir for
easter
in 2019. may we be heard and understood
from the suburbs to the hood may you
judge us by our hearts
and not by our mistakes and see that we
get our breakthrough
however long that it takes leading up to
the ceremony dmx's casket was driven in
the back of a monster truck
which had long lived dmx written on the
side
but the key thing is he maintained his
passion he maintained his strength
you know he was barking and growling on
stage
to hide the real things he was going
through
on sunday the tributes for dmx continued
during his funeral service
which was broadcast as part of bet
remembers dmx
homecoming celebration and featured many
emotional tributes from dmx's children
when my father passed someone messaged
me something that really stuck with me
they said the hardest thing ever is
accepting that this earth still rotates
without the people you love
you are more than my dad you are an icon
a legend always made sure we're good and
protected us
your energy is unmatched and there will
never be another dmx
you